[Music]
Comcast also 40 seconds of clock scored
logos and I'm afraid the sin counter
says your time is up dear Lois uncle
Jonathan narration I look forward to
meeting you cuz up with Jack Black's
accent here he's a warlock that lives in
goddamn Michigan not some gun-toting
Buster Scruggs impersonator yes sorry
for the stain on a letter that's
chocolate which I totally could have
wiped out but chose not to because how
else can the movie show that I'm fat and
love food more than I should
I love the reference of the rejected
title for Back to the Future but I just
want to watch back to the future instead
of sitting through this for the X
hundred and five minutes I do have a big
poker game tonight if you want to join
you play will be unexpectedly turns into
a rounders prequel worm turned out
differently than I expected I'll try to
keep it down around 3 a.m. but them's my
best jabbing hours sad part about this
is that we know jack black can play
different characters and this character
should be totally different from a
cookie cutter Jack Black performance but
I guess nobody told him to do anything
different than what he'd say on stage at
a tenacious D concert ratchet well shot
the quick Springs not far behind
Florence and the Machine this old hag is
my next-door neighbor mrs. Florence
Zimmerman I get the movie wants
everything to be presented all weird and
kooky for the kids but Florence's absurd
eyeglasses do just fine on their own no
need for her to come out of the clock
all Webster style for her introduction
I'm relieved to see you didn't inherit
your uncle's freakishly oversized head
huh says the woman who literally looks
like a q-tip answer how would you like
them sir stuffed down your throat one by
one or crumbled up and shoved into your
pants sexy banter did that Oh
he winced oh why are we all rooting for
Louis here sure he got screwed by his
parents died but he also pretty much
does whatever he wants to Falls
ass-backwards into a rich and magical
family and he's perfectly fine with
cheating at cards also why weren't the
cards laid down as soon as Jonathan in
Florence laid there stands nothing else
to think about the hand is over your
uncle drives me nuts but he's gotten me
out of more tough scrapes than I care to
mention
I guess I'm thankful for the vague
exposition here instead of using
flashbacks or something to give the
history of these two but they like just
met Louis might want to start with
showing him with a bathroom or the
pantry is right also good thing this
movie isn't called the house with the in
its walls am i right because I
definitely would have already started
writing some fanfic about glory hole
involving uncle Jonathan in Florence
over the past year I've found that all
one really needs in this world is one
good friend
I'm sure you've got lots yeah terms even
if he did they'd be in many states away
since he literally just moved a new
Zebedee seems like a weird thing to keep
bringing up reminders of this kids dead
parents and past life honestly you could
tell me this is shot from this movie
goosebumps miss Peregrine's Hogwarts for
gifted youngsters really does all roll
together doesn't it character is late
for his first day of school for no real
reason cliche maybe next time ankle
biter Jesus Christ really must we have
the protagonist of the movie immediately
bullied by his peers despite showing no
reason for them to do so except the
weird goggles and if it's the weird
goggles that are turning these little
assholes off why use ankle-biter when
four-eyes bugboy Jeepers Creepers and a
million other more appropriate insults
are right there this mother burger was
almost the whole movie with these
goggles and we've just seen him use them
in the basketball game
so why the fuck doesn't he put them on
during this batting practice when he
completely is exposed up the middle I'm
just trying to help us both out you
can't vote for me if you don't have arms
wow I didn't realize that in the 50s
voter suppression tactics were taught
all the way back in middle school ah
sudden Willie J Potter first you get the
book then you get big G if selena has a
very specific request why doesn't she
just tell Louis specifically where that
gets also how the hell did she get in
here we see later on that Isaac can't
even crack the front door and what the
hell are all those jack-o'-lanterns
doing which one with Disney Pixar movie
about the girl that turns into the bear
or the one where Johnny Depp volunteers
to do a snuff film i confuse those once
in front of my six-year-old niece and I
still haven't heard the end of it
luckily for Lewis these scary images
hanging in the house of the Warlock
r-rated decidedly PG and not even like
1980s PG when you can get away with some
yeah but you should see this dude rope a
steer
then why the hell did it take Jonathan
so goddamn long to appear he was right
behind Lois when he started freaking out
instead of saying anything then he let
the poor bastard run through his house
of nightmares unaware of what was going
on the house likes you
houses don't like anything their houses
that's how sister also this movie is
like if pee-wee's Playhouse the Haunted
Mansion and I'm honestly not sure if
that's a sin or not yet but for now this
house used to be owned by another
warlock Isaac Ezard and his wife Selena
what about his son Eddie he passed away
and left a magic clock in the walls
abracadabra credits put a clock in the
walls to drive me nuts try to drown it
out with all those other clocks but it
doesn't really work I'm sure it doesn't
considering you've intensified the
ticking to an insane degree do you to be
born a boy wait overlooked no no
character says he's not going to do
something immediately before doing it
Klee shit what smells of rancid sofa the
Griffin shrub may smell like rancid
sulfur but considering this can joke the
movie itself smells far worse also
seriously
consider the amount of time and effort
it took the effects Department to draw
animate and implement a scene in which
this characters into a goddamn pool all
because the screenwriters laughed about
the scenario after their third Long
Island iced tea longs it's bad what
didn't Jonathan think it was prudent to
go over any of this when Lewis first got
to the house I mean he could have opened
that door at any time just out of
curiosity even can't come within 20 feet
of that cabinet much less open it why
not surround the entire house in this
combo of spells charms and both don't
open that cabinet this is pretty much
the only thing I'm serious about so I
need to hear you saying even though I
waited several days to even bring up the
super off-limits check-offs cabinet
kidding and briefly believes he is back
in a David Lynch movie and starts
spilling nonsensical dialogue just out
of reflex I just think it might be
easier for you if you lost the goggles
acted a little more normal
what star B's game here he's spending
all the spring time with Louis just to
get his vote in the school election then
he's gonna abandon their friendship
that's a long-ass con man does this
asshole turn out to be Sawyer from lost
Jesus they are out in the middle of the
courtyard right and we've established
that things are easy to overhear in this
neighborhood maybe do this in the parlor
room or at least keep the incantations
down a little
you just have to quiet down and listen
now it looks like you're pooping I'll be
honest I read this book back of the day
and I loved it
also remember 100% fewer jokes about in
the original material let me show you
what a little weird can you this is
definitely filed under things you do not
want to hear from your uncle that you
still barely know I guess before this
spell can work it needs a little fizz
play to warm things up that way jinx
go-to moment dad's funeral I don't
really think she would have wanted me
there although she was apparently cool
in your ass to my house in case anything
happened to her so if the spells are
written in a different language than why
are the titles and explanation written
in English when Guardium 11 no sobs also
I haven't seen wirework this fucking
obvious since the first Highlander movie
good thing one of the spells Lewis
learned was how to possess water
fountains damn I thought it took a long
time to become a proper warlock I know I
know Lewis is a smart kid and a fast
learner but it's not like dr. fucking
strange even he took a while to get this
lingering thing down show me what you
got
so he's not saying a spell or anything
here he's just moving his hands around
and no the it's magic theory is not good
enough especially when Jonathan and
Florence made a big deal about technique
earlier plan button down please every
goddamn movie about magic has to include
a shot of some lazy ass kid using it to
do something that would take two seconds
like think Hayden Christensen hopping up
from the couch to pink kitchen and
jumper and it's enraging dude it's not
called the house with the clock in its
furniture the secret room is entirely
too large for to go completely unnoticed
Jonathan never thought kind of weird
there's this big-ass construction piece
sticking out of the back of the house I
mean there are windows and everything
Kirby I mean it we can't don't be such a
scaredy-cat kinked RB what's necromancy
didn't Jonathan say this cabinet was
guarded with all kinds of magical but
any old asshole except for Isaac and
Selena can open it the key was right
there man the key was right there okay
Jonathan do you wanna play ball with me
I can't right now there's something I
need to look into later okay okay
and the cat's in the cradle in the
silver spoon little boy blue and the man
moon weird beard cranky old crone much
brush hag face really sexy banner just
already and he's always nice until the
election after that he goes back to
being him this book wormy girl that
shows up to give pity advice to the
protagonist BMJ any harder man whoever
was buried here was metalist I almost
want to remove us in four but who the
hell would order a tomb like this unless
it was like let me well what I mean that
it's a kid screaming I don't want to
raise up a kid
it's creepy there you know that great
but Toby is here to watch
was raised a dead person so let's cut it
with the strong opinions on taste
looks like Edie Lorraine Warren are
gonna have their hands full hey I guess
whatever keeps the conjuring French on
is making cheese is good with it
the house masseuse back can you feel
that I got a dog with rabies no C's
masters coming home that's not all works
you're the smartest which I've ever
known I said I can't I can't
what's how you saying well the most
powerful Wizards ever is coming back to
life to destroy the universe and a super
powerful good magician is refusing to
help leaving it to a young boy do the
heavy lifting to defeat him never ever
before these are crazy people marmalades
we find out later that this is
definitely Selena in mrs. Han chat form
which means this is solely a fake up for
the audience and is some severe
marmalade you think these are enough to
keep Isaac out oh yes if the
jack-o'-lanterns already are there to
scare away evil then why do they need
the horseshoes and if they did need the
horseshoes why weren't they already
there before Isaac was resurrected
something is wrong something is very
wrong
sorry Kate no matter how many times you
or anyone else in the set said this to
Eli Roth this is the movie that we ended
up getting it's not safe for you here
so go next door thorns because being
five feet away from the house will
magically make Lewis safe it won't need
better protect it in the house
surrounded by jack-o'-lanterns and
horseshoes wait I think it uncle
Jonathan needs to perform together they
did everything together Wow even Selena
months passed then suddenly
Isaac came back home even if Lawrence is
manipulating this viewer with magic how
they did she get footage of Isaac
returning to his house after the war a
teacher who gave him some terrifying
forbidden books one of which is so
dangerous that your uncle keeps it
locked up in his cabinet his fucking
cabinet is the most infuriating part of
this whole fucking movie first off
Jonathan keeps that cabinet in the wide
can open library second he tells Lois
not to open it but of course doesn't
tell him what which is as good as an
invitation to any kid and finally
remember how the key is in the drawer of
that same cabinet and he found himself a
witch Selina so spiteful and mean he
married her oh good we're being
introduced to the main villains an hour
into the film
I'm not scared if you tell anyone I was
there I mean both your arms Frank
Underwood origins if you go back a page
or two you'll get the word impossible
which is exactly what this book opening
up to this definition is also huh I
guess getting punched activates Lewis's
zoom and enhance abilities
it's a Doomsday Clock did this really
need to be in code it's not like
Jonathan hasn't desperately tried to
find the clock anyway so why would
knowing what it is make that much of a
difference so this is my fault I didn't
say that then what are you saying man
they really had to shoehorn in this
protagonist fight before the climax of
the movie cliche yeah I'm almost
impressed but not enough to refrain from
Sinan I just wanted to be my friend
again King thar be having a child means
being scared for them 24/7 and doing it
anyway movie about some magical bolt in
the walls of a haunted house with a
doomsday scenario in which some terrible
CG is involved has time for this
contemplative rumination on the nature
of child-rearing isaac is the all
powerful warlock who can't open at all
Isaac has been out of the grave for at
least a day it's not too soon what's he
been doing this whole time biding his
time if so for what why didn't you just
come to the house right away and get the
key why should I stay away from Jesus
these effects look better when men and
black used them over twenty years ago
not my bone no that was a chunk from the
real mrs. Han shit
don't these two have some doomsday to do
instead of exposing their plan to a
ten-year-old boy mmm my wife she has a
talent for disguises but why has she
been in one this whole time pretending
to be calling camp for the last year she
could have pretended to be mrs.
Zimmerman talk Jonathan did too giving
her the book or key looking anything
else more useful than being calling camp
with a dog Isaac took him yes but where
I think I know all it took was a good
old-fashioned manhunt to get Florence's
magical lady boner engorged all on the
contrary it's where I met my teacher
exposition projection projects position
I stumbled through the black forest for
days again with the highly edited
footage of Isaac's past is this looking
thing seriously a pensive so what was
your plan here straight up murder Lois
would that do anything except piss
Jonathan and foreign sophomore it sure
is convenient when the protagonist can
and can't magic isn't it like they
didn't even try anything spells on these
assholes Oh My giddy aunt My giddy aunt
Lois I don't know about that 8-ball
by magic what a coincidence that's
exactly what I said the last time I did
an Eightball wait there are even more
rooms in this motherfucker this house
must have an enormous carbon footprint
yeah but if the spell made him an infant
why is his head adult size I'm flagging
this movie for blatant misuse of CG and
good sense 15 yards five-minute major
and three red cards damn it movie
realizes that no one has ever seen a
jack black headed baby pee but it never
stopped to ask the question if anyone
should see it
magic 8-ball Akaka know something is
wrong I'm going with the entire third
act of this movie seriously this was an
interesting premise that got completely
by a dude that's more accustomed to
making torture porn commercially viable
[Music]
right up don't pick a fight with me you
certain you're gonna come out alive I
believe in the voters they understand
that elections aren't just popularity
contests
ever since the Luke disappeared people
been looking for him why did he leave
one boy an apprentice turned against him
destroyed it all you know how I said
there were no rules actually there's one
rule you do not talk about Fight Club
that's not a hostage as Einstein said
wherever you go there you are
you sure look sparkly peewee Thank You
Jerry not blaspheme Malachi you know not
the laws he speaks them only to me but
I'm gonna need some Ovaltine Tony sure
you drink your Ovaltine Swami commercial
but it is doc upstairs when I'm
frightened of the dark